despite there being two more women on
the Forbes 400 this year as a group the
richest women in America are worth 29
billion dollars less than last year the
58 women on this year's ranking are
worth a combined 535 billion dollars
down from 564 billion dollars last year
the biggest change came at the top Julia
Koch the Widow of coke Industries
billionaire David Koch is now the
richest woman in America unseating
Walmart heiress Alice Walton who had
held the top spot since 2015. as of
September 2nd when Forbes locked in net
worths Coke was worth an estimated 56
billion dollars up from 51 billion
dollars from a year ago thanks to her 42
stake in Koch Industries the industrial
conglomerate run by Koch's
brother-in-law Charles meanwhile Alice
Walton's Fortune fell by 12.2 billion
dollars to an estimated 55.7 billion
dollars as Walmart shares tumbled 11
percent amid dish Year's market sell-off
and Forbes revised its Assumption of her
stake in the family's holding trust
behind coking Walton is Mackenzie Scott
who got a quarter of Jeff bezos's stake
in Amazon in their 2019 divorce shares
of the e-commerce giant are down 27
percent knocking 16.8 billion dollars
off her net worth Scott's
record-breaking philanthropic work has
also made a dent she donated 12.6
billion dollars since June 2020
including 4 billion dollars in the past
year meanwhile Four Women joined the
ranks of the 400 this year the richest
newcomer is philanthropist and art
collector Edith broad worth an estimated
6.9 billion dollars whose husband home
building an insurance magnate Eli bro
died in 2021. 10 of the women are
self-made they include the richest
self-made women in America Diane
Hendricks co-founder and chair of
roofing supply company ABC Supply worth
an estimated 12.2 billion dollars
[Music]
thank you